en france nouvelle grève d établissement
français du sang aujourd'hui depuis hier
soir les professionnels de la collecte
du sang se mobilisent contre la
suppression des effectifs et pour une
revalorisation de leurs salaires un
mouvement qui a déjà été initiée le 21
octobre dernier mais qui a été peu
visible dans ce secteur pourtant
essentiel pour la santé on va en parler
avec notre reporter sur place devant le
siège de l'établissement français du
sang en seine saint denis nadège à
peyriac
[Musique]
bonjour nallet alors qu'est ce qu'on
peut attendre de cette mobilisation
aujourd'hui
écoutez les syndicats de l'établissement
français du sang alerte sur le niveau
très bas de leur réserve et appelle les
français à donner leur sang alors à ces
dernières semaines les stocks de sang
sont descendues en dessous du seuil
d'alert avec 75 mille poches de sang
pour un besoin de 100 mille poches la
pandémie de kobe de 19 ans est en effet
en partie en tout cas responsable de
cette diminution puisque les collectes
n'ont pas pu se tenir de manière
habituelle de manière normale au cours
des 18 derniers mois mais pour les
syndicats cette baisse des dons est
également dû à un manque d'effectif 300
postes seraient en effet en manque il
manquerait à 300 postes niveau national
suite à la non application du ségur de
la santé à l'établissement français du
sang seul établissement public de santé
d'importance vitale oublié par l'état et
à la politique de diminution d'effectifs
mise en place depuis des années
l'établissement français du sang
n'arrive plus à recruter n'arrive plus à
fidéliser son personnel
vous l'avez entendu les syndicats de
l'établissement français du sang
réclament également une revalorisation
salariale sur l'ensemble des
professionnels au moins du style à la
hauteur de l'accord du ségur de la santé
alors le gouvernement
je le rappelle s'était engagé à investir
plus de 8 milliards d'euros par an pour
revaloriser les métiers de la santé et
des et pas dans l'objectif c'était de
reconnaître justement l'engagement des
soignants auprès des français mais les
représentants de l'établissement
français du sang se disent exclus de ces
mesures en partie
merci beaucoup de neige pour toutes ces
précisions nadège ad razak devant
l'établissement français du sang pour
une grève qui va durer toute la semaine